here with reaction house Judiciary
Committee chairman Ohio Congressman Jim
Jordan
sir Congressman great to see you good to
be with you SE um I have that breaking
news any reaction on your end to that I
I I I don't even remember what she's
talking about I I'm in so many hearings
I I try to question the witness in an
appropriate fashion so I don't know what
she's talking about I do think we are
gathering support though across the
Congress uh across the conference from
from conservatives to more moderate
members of our conference and I feel
that's important because I really think
Sean this this election for speakers
about two issues who can bring our team
together who can unite our conference
and who can go tell the American people
what we're doing and why it's important
to them and I think I can do that that's
why I'm running I I've told I've been on
the phone all day long with colleagues
from around the country and I tell them
the job I have I like I want to keep I I
like that job but someone's got to be
able to come forward unite the Republic
around our message around what we're
doing for the American people and go
make that take that message to the
country and deliver it in a compelling
succinct way which I think I can do I
think the one thing that there is
definitely consensus on and I I talked
to this great audience before the show
is number one they want to make sure
that the investigations that you have
started and Jason Smith and James comr
continue uh I'm sure they will am I
correct to my
assumption yeah they have to I mean it's
it's important uh the way these agencies
have been turned on we the people on the
American people we have to continue that
work I mean I was in a deposition two
days ago when all this was happening on
the house floor relative to our speaker
I was in a deposition with the US
attorney from the District of Columbia
Matthew Graves who wouldn't partner with
with David Weiss in the hunter bid
investigation and when they were talking
about bringing the bman chart so we were
doing our work that all continues but we
got to come together as a as a
conference come together as Republicans
so that work can continue so we can deal
with the Border so we can deal with the
issues we told the American people we
were going to address so one other thing
that I'm hearing very loudly from
people's is they want to see the
Republicans they don't want to get stuck
here they don't want 15 more votes they
want this settled and they want you guys
back to work are you confident that
that's going to happen by this time next
week are you confident that we're going
to have a new speaker and it's going to
be you it has to happen we shouldn't go
to the house floor until we have 218
votes for the speaker of the United
States House of represent we shouldn't
have to go through what we did back in
January I'm all for that I think I can
bring our team together to accomplish
that and more importantly once we get
that done to do the work that needs to
be done on the border on crime on
inflation on all these issues we have to
address I think I can do that that's why
I decided to run so let's go through the
top agenda items I would say off the top
of my head this border really does have
to get secure secondly we had $2
trillion of Biden debt last year you
know what that is unacceptable able
we're now at $33.5 trillion in debt that
we're putting on our kids and grandkids
that's got to stop uh will we get back
to regular order will we go through the
Appropriations process will we secure
the Border will we bring Law and Order
to American cities and and will there be
all these other votes that members have
been talking about term limits etc etc
etc we we we brought up we brought up
term limits in in in the committee last
week and had a vote on that legislation
in the committee last week yeah we need
to do all that Sean but in 40 days the
stop Gap spending measure runs out we
have to have a plan as a conference
again when we elect our new speaker we
have to have a plan that 218 of us
support on how we're going to deal with
that how are we going to deal with when
we get to November we can't have the
same thing unfold that unfolded last
week so I think that we have to look at
another stop Gap measure that would kick
in the 1% cut there's legislation in
place right now that says if we have a
CR that continuing resolution that goes
into next year there's an automatic 1 %
cut that takes place there's nothing
like a cut to spending that focuses
politicians attention so we need that
threat hanging there to be leverag for
us to get the policies you just talked
about the policies where we can win on
the border issue on the crime issue on
infl that's what but that's the only way
this town can operate is when there's
that when there's that kind of Leverage
and there's that kind of deadline
hanging there where real cuts are going
to happen that we can actually get
people to focus and get our work done so
that's what I think we have to do in
order to deal with what's coming in 40
short days if you're elected speaker you
will have 15 months to prove to the
Republican uh caucus uh and Conference
uh how good a job you do and then in
January 2025 you will hopefully be up
for reelection if you win to be speaker
again that would be your vote of
confidence where do you stand on this
one member motion to vacate triggered by
any one member which means anytime it's
triggered all other business in the
house stops uh should that threshold be
raised yeah our conference it's been
loud and clear the feedback I get from
our conference our conference wants to
change that I'm for changing that but we
got to have 218 Republicans to do it CU
that is actually a house Rule and you
got to be able to go to the floor of the
house and change that I'm for doing that
if we have 218 I don't want to go to the
Democrats and make that change because
they're going to want all kinds of
things so let's work as a unit and deal
deal with the problems we see in this
country as a unit so we can stop where
the left wants to take us every
Republican here's my message to all of
you guys you're either going to win as a
team you're going to win together or
you're going to lose so you better unite
you have a small majority you have a lot
of power that has been entrusted to you
now make it work and just keep your
promises it's that simple uh Congressman
great to see you and maybe this time
next week I'll be addressing you as Mr
Speaker I don't know hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not not get it anywhere
else